next up watching thanks for the
introduction and today I'm going to talk
about optimal lower bounds for
distributing the streaming spanning
forest computation and this is a joint
work with July Nelson let's first do a
warm-up and consider in a following
dynamic data structure problem streaming
problem depending on which community you
belong to so the problem is your first
given a initially empty graph G n
vertices and I'm going to do updates to
this graph and every in every update I
can insert an edge I can insert this
add-in says that edge and I will also
make queries when I make a query the
data structure you designed or you must
do output a spanning forest of G of the
current version of this graph and the
goal is to use minimum space so the
space will be the main parameter in the
stock and I'm not going to worry about
how much time you take to handle these
updates and queries so if you think
about this problem the space complexity
its space complexity is quite easy to
understand which is n log n bits for the
upper bound you can just maintain a list
of edges in the spanning forest and
every time I inserted edge if it's
already connected if two endpoints are
already connected then you throw it away
otherwise you're added to the list and
list it can't contain at most n minus 1
edges and each edge constant is log n
bits to describe and that one uses all
of n log n bits and for the lower bound
when the final graph when I make the
query itself is a tree then have two
basic up through the entire graph and
bikeways formula there are n to the N
minus two trees on n vertices so in
order to distinguish every pair I
basically have to spend and log n bits
this is a lower bound so this is the
space complexity of this problem when
there are only instructions is out of n
log n bits up to a constant factor so
what happens if we allow edge regions so
in this problem I'm only asked inserting
edges so what happens I can also delete
edges during each update so that the
solution we had before it doesn't work
when there are traditions because
when I add that was not that is not
useful when it's insertion when in the
insert model we can just throw it away
but when the intelligence it might be
useful later at the query time so in
extreme case where example with the
insert may be all possibly edges then
start deleting edges and - I have only n
poly log n here just left and I asked
what is spanning forest then if you do
the calculation even if I sample for
example n to the 1.9 edges at the
beginning that's still not sufficient
enough to guarantee a high probability
of having a spanning forest starting a
memory at the end
so this problem seems much harder but it
turns out that there is a very space
efficient solution if we our
randomization and a small error
probability so on Guha and the edge
McGregor designed an elegant solution to
this problem that uses all of n log n
cubed bits of space and with error
probability 1 over polygon so comparing
this solution to the incremental
spanning forest problem this is using
only two more log factors and the exact
same algorithm with a different setting
of parameters actually gives you a
smooth trade-off between the space usage
and the error probability Delta so
somewhere where there are probabilities
is Delta then this algorithm uses n
Times log of n over Delta times log n
squared piece of space so one nature of
question here to ask is why are we using
two more log factors is it necessary can
we improve the bound for example if you
look at this this space bound here so
when for error probability counts for
constantly about beauty and for error
probability being one of our poly log n
in these two cases you get the same vote
in both cases you get and times log n
cubed bits but maybe this sounds a
little bit strange when I'm lowering
lowering the error probability I'm not
actually using more space maybe it is
possible to save one of log factors if I
only require say 0.1 error probability
it turns out that this is not possible
and our main one the first main result
of this paper is a tight lower bound for
fully dynamic spanning forest in this
case for almost of the full range of
error parameter of interest so we show
that any data structure for fully
dynamic spanning forest with error
probability Delta must use n Times log
of n over Delta times log n square the
bits of memory for any Delta between
0.99 and 2 to the minus n to the 0.99 so
the first observation is that we cannot
hope to prove this exact bound for all
possible Delta because for example there
exists an N squared bit solution namely
just remember the entire decision matrix
of the graph which achieves error
properties 0 so in particular when this
Delta is smaller than to the minus n we
cannot hope to prove a lower bound of
this phone but we prove this lower bound
prove this algorithm is actually tight
all the way up to almost this limit any
particular when when the error per meter
and a pair of ability Delta is a
constant it implies that we do need n
Times log n cubed piece of space and we
do need exactly two more log factors
comparing to the incremental vision
questions to be - I think and then this
load this this paper I mean this theorem
didn't say anything about this regime
but I think our s squared is alone
so can the upper bound some of them are
only handles like the air one over
pullian right but yeah so is there any
hope to push it towards smaller maybe
there's actually a smooth trade-off
between the air pressure and the space
so forth Arabic Arabic Delta you get n
Times log n over Delta Center log and
Square pizza
so there's smooth trade-off between from
constant to 2 to the minus n
so the upper bone can handle the regime
when everybody's like to the power minus
n to some constant power yeah yes oh
just a probe on would be used useless
because if Delta is a 2 to that and
something you get on that I mean you
could get ants quit yeah it depends on
what this something is smaller than 1
yeah force more than one it's still use
yeah that is a 1 1 yeah
and it turns out that this same solution
the AGM sketch also solves the following
and player communication game in the
simultaneous communication model
sometimes also referred to as
distributed scheduled model so what is
this communication game so this
communication game has n players with
the shared randomness with shared random
bits and the input is a fixed graph on n
versus okay now there are no in search
engines so we just have one fixed graph
and n vertices and this input graph is
distributed to n players such that each
player only sees what the name of one
vertex and the names of its neighborhood
okay then depending on what this based
on what they see they are going to send
one message to a special player called
the referee then the referee has to
output must outputs manifolds with high
probability based on all these messages
and of course in the communication model
that goal is to minimize communication
so in some sense this problem is joint I
mean this setting is trying to compute a
global function of the huge input giving
small circuit sketches of local
information which could be useful in
some distributed setting where the whole
input is too large to fit in one machine
then we distribute it into different
machines such that each machine computes
a small sketch of this local local
information of this input graph and then
it computes a global function evaluate
all function value based on all these
small sketches so the same solution the
ATM sketch also gives an efficient
communication protocol for this
simultaneous communication
game so using a worst-case log of n over
delta x log n squared piece of
communication per player with error
probability Delta for any Delta greater
than zero
consistency is guaranteed that's the
promise right what the player see yes
yes will correspond to some consistent
graph and they all see the same share
randomness and also the referee also
sees these measurements
and for this somebody is a communication
game there's also a trivial log and
lower bound because there are free has
to out of a spanning forest which needs
who needs to learn n log n bits of
information so on average each player
has to send log n bits and again for
constant our probabilities this is using
exactly two more log factors and the
second and main result of this paper is
this algorithm is again tied in this
setting we show that any simultaneous
communication protocol for a spanning
forest computation with error
probability 0.99 must use log and cubed
bits of communication on average so an
average player expectation has to send
this many bits if error curve it is a is
a constant bounded bounded away from one
so this is exactly we show that's
exactly two more log factors needed and
attribute information service color
bound and it's an issue interesting open
question is that it turns out that our
technique doesn't apply talent gave us a
higher lower bound when the error curve
is lower in this setting unlike the
previous streaming setting we got two
for trade off for our parameters of
Delta so for even if data is something
like 2 to the minus square root of n of
techniques to make gives log n cubed
bits of lower bound so initial squared
question would be whether we can get
higher lower one of this is closer to
one we don't know yet so well in this
lower bound only holds when error per
bit is founded away from one
so in these two settings although this
to this problem is in these two settings
are solved by the same solution but if
you think about it scene it turns out
that the hardest are the most difficult
part in these two settings actually
coming from different places so in the
first streaming setting where we have
insertions and deletions the most
difficult part is to handle these
solutions because without them is the
problem easy but the data structure is
allowed to look at the whole memory
after each update and during the query
time so there's no local issue the
openness issue in this setting and in
the simultaneous communication problem
there are no insertion in traditions and
the main challenge is to handle this
trying to compose messages that only
depend on a local structure of the graph
and because of these two differences I
mean one can imagine that the Hani's
proof should explore a different should
be quite different because we should
exploit different parts of the harness
and and in this talk I will only focus
on one of these proofs the second one
the lower bound proof for someone his
communication game in the rest of the
talk okay maybe before we go into the
actual details of the proof it makes
sense to look at the how how the upper
bound works maybe from a high level so
the most important part of the upper
bound is probably the is probably a
linear sketch that the the agent paper
designed a randomized linear sketch that
map's a random a random linear sketch
that map's maps a graph which can viewed
as n square dimensional vector into a
much shorter vector of length n Times
log n square such that this is a linear
mapping with the polynomial bounded
coefficients which means in the in the
output of this mapping each coordinate
has polynomial bound it introduced which
means you can encode each code into
using log n bits so that in code to
encode the output it takes n Times log n
cubed bits
and moreover this output it can be
viewed as a concatenation of n things
such that in the ice block it has log n
squared dimensions and this ice chunk
can be computed from some local
information for the graph from the
neighborhood of vertex I and there more
importantly by looking at the sketch the
whole sketch it determines spanning
forest with high-profit with probability
1 minus 1 over poly N and this
probability is over the randomness of
the random choice of the linear sketch
and for every instance so you know just
so the streaming problem we just store
as of T this linear sketching memory and
for each update because it's a linear
sketch we can just compute the sketch of
this single edge and then add it to the
graph or maybe subtracted from it and at
the end of a stream this look by looking
at to the host sketch determines a
spanning forest with the high
probability and as we argued before it
uses n Times log n cubed piece of space
and for the communication problem the
ITR just based on his local information
computes the ice chunk of the output and
the census to referee the referee
concatenates all these Sivaji and obtain
obtained the entire sketch and the base
on which he will be he will be able to
output a spanning forest with high
probability and this is a log n cube
means of communication for player s of G
and from SG you can come computer
spanning forest with high probability
confuse about how it's getting used in
the second application because when
there's an image right two players are
going to be some sunsets do the sketch
with that edge in mind yes things that
sometimes in I mean he some step of this
construction you need to cancel these
edges in order to find something useful
they were appearing both players imports
and what they were appearing both
sketches
this this uses this I mean the public
random is candid and also you can say
the higher I mean every vertex has the
name and the name with higher verdicts
has positive signs
so either you know many of the stock I'm
going to give a high-level idea how we
prove this cemetery's communication
lower for spending forest so again just
recall that immersive graph is given to
each player and H purse is one local
structure of the graph and send one
message to the referee who has two
artists spanning first and our theorem
proves that an average player must send
log and Q bits when the error
probability is a constant and for this
talk I'm going to do two simplifications
one is I'm going to show prove that at
the worst player or there exist a player
who must send log n cubes bits and I'm
going to assume that the the the
protocol succeeds with high probability
with partly 1 over polygons and he in
fact these two simplifications can be
you getting rid of gotten rid of very
simple but fairly easily but I'm going
not going to get into this in stock so C
is much larger than 2
sure in fact any constant 0.1 is
so the starting point of the lower bound
proof is the communication problem
universal relation and in fact it it's a
special case of this problem in one-way
communication
this special case in this special case
we have two previous areas in the Bob so
a discussed once that usually it's a you
can think of it's a binary string so as
guess one set s and Bob gets another set
T which is a proper subset of s and in
this one-way communication problem has
to go into a look at her inputs and the
share random bits and send one message m
to Bob and Bob based on everything he
sees output some outputs must output
element in the difference with her
probability
so the complexity or the one-way
communication complexity of universal
Eurasian subsets in this stream is as
well is completely understood so a
couple of it proves a tight low bound
for this problem and in particular when
Delta is at least 2 to the minus n to
the 0.99 the Aloha bond simplifies to
log of 1 over Delta times log N squared
so in particular when the failure
probability Delta is 1 over poly and
this the lower bound keeps the optimal
ends being log n cubed and this is where
the log in cubed in your bank um comes
from but maybe at this point it might
still not be clear why University
relation is related to a spanning forest
in simultaneous communication but on the
next slide I'm going to present this
connection why it's related to
university relation and then presents
the key idea of our reduction so suppose
that a now you have one of the players
in this simultaneous communication game
you'd like to compute spanning forest
then what you see is one vertex V in the
graph and also a bunch of other vs. who
are neighbors u1 up to u pay and this is
the picture you see then based on this
picture you send one message M sub B to
the referee and all sort of a freak
that's a bunch of other inputs and based
on all these inputs they're free has to
compute a spanning forest ok suppose
after you have composed the same message
M sub B I suddenly tell you that there's
a subset of your neighbors this purple
subset such that for all verses in there
you are this vertex B is their only
neighbor ok so what this mean it means
that the Rafi in order to find a
spanning forest the only way for this
purpose at and V to connect to the rest
of graph is through an edge from B to
some other vertex in your neighborhood
so if you view the set B as the
neighbors the neighbors of B as a set s
and view this purpose at the set of
verses that whose set V is the only
neighbor as I said T then in order to
find out spanning four
you must the referee must find some
elements in the difference in s minus T
this makes sense so why doesn't already
what this doesn't present to this
already give us an login cube lower
bound this is it because the Rafi finds
a spanning forest face down all messages
from all end players so even if I send a
message M sub B to the free the Rafi may
still learn something about my
neighborhood from other messages for
example the message from vertex u one
may also review this at the SW one and
it it's not necessarily coming from this
message absolutely so so to circumvent
this issue we are going to consider the
following hard instances so the hardness
of our reduction will be a carpeted
graph consider three parts and the
middle column will be the vs. remaining
consider correspond to the vertex u in
the last picture okay so the middle
middle column will have n to the 1 minus
epsilon vertices and the right column
will have much fewer
n to the epsilon and the left column we
have n verses which are divided into
blocks of size n to the epsilon such
that each vertex in the middle has a
corresponding block on the left okay so
the idea is that we are going to
randomly permute the name of these
vertices such that if you are one of
these vertex VI in the middle when you
see a neighborhood you don't know which
ones are on the left and which ones on
the right then for each vertex VI we are
going to use its neighborhood to encode
some set s sub I and then we are going
to use its neighborhood on the left to
encode some subset some subset of SI TI
and we construct graph to guarantee that
all the other groups on the left capital
VI their only neighbor might the
corresponding verticals in the middle
little VI could be their only neighbor
that means in order to
connected to the rest of the graph the
spanning forest must find for every bi
in the middle some edge connecting to
connecting VI and to the right and
because we are encoding set TI as the
neighborhood on the left then this
corresponding to finding some element in
the difference of Si energiya so so why
are we in constructing such a graph so
imagine that you have the referee and
suppose that you receive all the
messages but do you don't see the
messages from the right column so you
don't see this message from here you
only see message from the left two
columns then from the left column what
can you learn so from left to call them
every vertex you only learn one bit
either whether I mean whether they are
connected to the vertex in the middle so
from all these messages the only thing
you learn is set ti4 for every I and for
the messages from the committed column
everyone composes a message this depends
only on the set TSI without knowing what
T is so if you if the referee doesn't
actually see any message from the right
column essentially he is trying to solve
n to the 1 minus epsilon independent
instance of the universal relation so
for every pair Si and ti there's one of
such instances but the the point is we
said set up this graph the point is
there are so few verses on the right so
the all messages from the right column
combined the length is much smaller than
the number of vertices in the middle
column so all these messages combined
cannot review much information about a
random vertex in the middle so
essentially for a random instance in the
middle that the referee is still trying
to solve this universal relation program
so our higher instance will be first
randomly partition the verses in two
different sets VI and also v r2 to run
ma famille to the names and then for
each vertex VI in the middle generates
how the instance from universal
instance then we connect each vertex VI
2 TI random vs. on the left and then
connect run si minus TI random versus al
right
and this completes the hardest
so in order to prove you have the maker
reduction
the idea is to embed a universal
relation instance into one of these SI
energy is and then try to construct the
whole graph and assimilate the spanning
forest protocol so the goal of this
embedding is to first we want to
generate a graph G that looks like a
hard instance so when I s keep areas
country coming from the universal
relation having instance I want my graph
tree to look like the had instance from
the previous slide and also I want to
the spanning forest which is output of
this protocol to tell us an element in
the difference which will be output of
the universal relation problem and I
want to make this reduction
I want to this reduction with low
communication cost and preserves the
success probability due to the time
constraints are probably I won't have
time to go through all these all the
details but point is we are going to
construct some graph such as a
convenient NSG pair the distribution of
G is a hard instance and for every if
people we can find a spanning forest
than by finding one labor of B di in the
middle that is in the right we will be
able to find some element in the
difference and eventually because of
this so before we have argument that
under the right column has very few
vertices so in total there will be very
little information about the
neighborhood of the middle column so by
en if we don't know the messages from
the right we can still estimate or learn
what is one neighbor of the vertex VI on
the right with high probability and the
difference here will be there will be a
relative error of 1 over N to the point
1 so at the end we will get a protocol
with fair probability delta plus 1 over
n to the point 1 and with the
communication cost same
the communication cost in the seven days
communication model and invited the
lower bound from universal from
universal relation we get log n cubed
lower bound when the error probability
is one of our poly n so because of this
additive whenever n to the point one
term we want to be able to get a higher
lower bound even if the the initial
error probability is much smaller it
will always be absorbed into this term
so one open question is whether can we
whether we can prove a higher lower
bound for this in this model when the
error probability is actually much
smaller can we prove no one that matches
the double bond of log n over Delta x
log N squared and also our government
proof uses heavily the fact that we're
actually computing a spanning forest
what rather than maintaining maybe
disconnected components of maintaining
the one bit if the whole graph is
connected so it's in interest question
to study whether we can prove the same
lower bound if the problem is just to
maintain this one bit if the whole graph
is connected or not and for this problem
the personal half pump is still the same
log and cubed if our probability is
[Applause]
yeah they're in the stream model there's
I mean we use a completely different
argument to the point there is that we
probe we basically prove that finding
one neighbor for each vertex in the end
of the stream is already hard so that I
mean that corresponds to so being an
independent instance of universal
relation or support finding so we should
protect you can focus on the sparrow
types I can insert and they insert a
neighbor of the different neighbor at
the end I want to find any neighbor of
this vertex so there will be any
instance of this
so that's the main idea but the argument
you just think watching you
[Applause]